[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF GOLDBERG: My favorite
thing about this photo
is watching people react to it.
Most people look
at it and see all
of the photographers
looking in one direction,
and it takes them a second
or two before they notice
the bear is right behind them.
And then they get a big
smile on their face or laugh
or have some shocked reaction.
And then they look up at
me and ask me if it's real.
When I tell them it is, we
generally laugh together.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: I'm going to
assume that a lot of you
had the same reaction when you
looked at this picture-- shock,
surprise, doubt, amazement.
And that's all
because of this guy.
JEFF GOLDBERG: Hi, my
name is Jeff Goldberg.
I live in Grayslake, Illinois.
I'm a retail consultant
and avid photographer.
I took this photo
in Hallo Bay, Alaska
in part of the
Katmai National Park.
I was in Hallo Bay that day as
part of an extended photography
adventure with my son.
He had recently
graduated high school,
and before going
off to college, we
wanted to spend some time in the
wild observing grizzly bears.
NARRATOR: And there's
no better place
in the world to do that
then Katmai National Park.
It's home to one of the
largest protected grizzly bear
populations in the world,
making it a perfect--
if slightly dangerous-- place
to photograph these animals.
JEFF GOLDBERG: When I first saw
the bear approach this group,
my first reaction was,
how can they not see it?
It's so big.
And when they come close, I
can smell them and hear them,
and they make noises.
But I also understand
as a photographer,
I can be fixated on what
you see through the lens.
So then my second
reaction was nervous.
I was wondering if something
bad was going to happen.
Our guide told me this was
not an unusual occurrence
in Hallo Bay.
As long as they didn't
approach him or make
any sudden movements, they
would probably be fine.
Also, in his
estimation, the bear
wasn't as close as
it really seems.
And lastly, and
probably most important,
we didn't really have a way
to signal these photographers
as we were quite
some distance away.
NARRATOR: But everything
turned out OK.
The bear walked right
past the photographers
without some of
them even noticing.
And Jeff got a picture
that was pretty
different from what that pack
of photographers captured.
JEFF GOLDBERG: This trip was
wonderful in so many ways.
First was the complete
immersion in the wild lives
of these bears.
We spent a lot of time on
the ground with the bears,
really seeing how they
go about their lives--
the daily struggles, their fun
of playing with each other,
fighting with each
other, and really seeing
their constant
struggle for survival.
So being able to see the whole
story play out in front of us
was really a
tremendous experience
I got to have that
experience with my son--
these shared memories for
the rest of our lives.
And I really will treasure that.
NARRATOR: If you thought
this was a close encounter,
check out this
episode on what it's
like to get this close
to a great white shark.
JOE BUTLER: This
particular photo
was taken off of Hans
Bay, South Africa
in the late September of 2012.
We were in the area for
a university field course
looking at the
local biodiversity
and took the opportunity to
experience more charismatic sea
life we rarely get to see.
NARRATOR: And if you
loved this episode and you
really want more "Seeker"
videos, check out
"Seeker Stories"
on Vessel, where
you can get our videos three
days earlier than anywhere
else on the internet.
Click the link in
the description
for your free 30-day trial.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]